it's the height of the Cold War and the
Soviet Union wages of brutal campaign in
Afghanistan between 1980 and 1981 a
newcomer from Saudi Arabia arrives to
join the rebels trying to oust the
Soviets Osama bin Laden the Afghan
resistance now receives support from the
United States in Pakistan Saudi Arabia
and scores of Islamic volunteers
bin Laden brings money and an expertise
in construction according to two men who
worked alongside the future al-qaeda
leader he started building mountainside
caves for storage of ammunition and
started building roads he was very
generous with money with the people's
popular one all we I did when he was
with us helping us helping the poor
widows orphans organizing funds for some
needy people's we had no problem with
him at all at the time little about bin
Laden suggests the terrorist leader he
will become during the Afghan Soviet War
the CIA was aware of it but had no
reason to view bin Laden as a threat
says former spy michael Scheuer the
first time we heard about Osama bin
Laden he was involved first in refugee
care in the camps in Pakistan and then
we heard that he moved into Afghanistan
and began to have a unit of Arabs that
he commanded but he was on the side of
the angels then he was killing Russians
and so we didn't pay much attention to
him today US intelligence officers deny
they had any direct contact with bin
Laden they say the US aid went only to
the Afghans not to foreign Islamic
volunteers there are those in the media
who just loved to make the point that
CIA trained Afghan Arabs and bin Laden
it's a popular theory that it's not one
that has much traction people like bin
Laden came with their own money a
built-in hatred for America and access
to weaponry either from their own
sources or from the Pakistanis they
wanted nothing to do with us Pakistani
journalists rahimullah yousafzai is one
of the few reporters to interview bin
Laden more than once he says that
foreign Arab fighters like bin Laden had
little use for the CIA
was so much of Arab money coming here
that didn't need to get money from the
CIA or is a charitable contributions
from Saudi Arabia are rich enough to
support not only the Mujahideen but also
the many Afghan civilians made refugees
by the ongoing fighting over 4 million
Afghans are forced to flee their homes
for Pakistan one third of the population
was made homeless for a very long period
of time here along the border between
Afghanistan and Pakistan money from
Saudi Arabia sets up hundreds of Islamic
schools for madrasas to offer a free
education for the Afghan refugee
children these madrasah students are
known as talents or Taliban their
teachers are local mullahs like Mohammad
Omar
even today Afghan children memorize and
recite verses from the Koran but during
the desperate time of the Soviet War
many of these Islamic schools were used
for a different purpose in certain areas
these mothers were used to train the
people and their to send out the jihadis
into Afghanistan mullahs like Mohammad
Omar send the Taliban to fight the
Soviets with America's blessing
according to current Pakistani President
Pervez Musharraf
Taliban were the heroes in those days
people from madrasas were given military
training armed and sent across by US by
United States by every